dr zakiyah next question
doesn't there seem to be a contradiction
in the quran when it mentions in several
verses that everything happens by the
will of allah in and furthermore in one
verse
the good is from allah and the bad or
the evil is from yourself
the many was in the quran
which mentioned that
everything happened with the will of
allah as we discussed in the early
answer
but it's mentioned in surah nisa chapter
4 verse number 79
all the good that happened is it's
allah and all the evil it's from the
human beings on the face of it it seems
to be a contradiction
but if you realize the real meaning
there's no contradiction at all
for example the electricity comes from
the head power station
it's coming
the power is from the head station
and with that you can use good things we
can use equipment you can use machinery
but if we put our finger in a live wire
we will get a shock so the power is from
the headquarters
had electric station but if you put a
finger and do a thing which is not
supposed to be done then we get a shock
so the good is from the power station
but if
the power is cut from the headquarters
i'll not get a shock
but we cannot blame that because the
power is coming from there they are to
blame for the shock it is me who has put
the finger in live fire so i am to blame
but the power is coming from the head
electric station let me give you another
simpler example
that
the father is head of the family
he earns
and he spends on the family so he's
responsible for everything that is spent
but at the same time he gives pocket
money to his son
now with the pocket money what the son
receives he gambles
he has alcohol
so who's to blame
the person to blame for doing the sin of
gambling and having intoxication is the
son but the money is coming from the
father
so it's happening with the money of the
father but who's to blame
the son the same way everything happens
in the level
but if anything good takes place it's
because of allah any bad
it is because of you
so hope this example will make you
understand that there is a coalition
between both these verses there's not a
contradiction but it's the clarification
okay thank you dr zakiyah i'm sure that
sort that one out